yeah i mean and you've been through
the entire industry gauntlet a couple of
times hundred percent
because there's the first the first go
around when you guys you know we're
doing the young boy [ __ ]
exactly and were you guys who were you
guys tied to initially at interscope we
did two
yeah you guys did two different
interscope runs i still have a i still
have a black and white eight by twelve
autographed photo of you and octane from
like 2010.
with [ __ ] somewhere right shout out
to
[ __ ] all the people who ate off for
that first deal
shout out to y'all yeah but it's just
crazy because um
you've like you said two two runs
through interscope
right under obviously much different
circumstances yeah
um and you know
some like like some people don't got it
in them to keep going with this [ __ ] 100
because because you guys could could
have taken that last go round with
with the hs 87 wave and and even like
but you guys
you know much pr props to the to the
good vibe tribe project like you guys
still were putting out incredible music
yeah but i feel like
when you're like put out so much [ __ ]
like
and and like you guys obviously have had
some mild commercial success but never
really like
blue exactly like i feel like once come
as you are came out i thought it was
over yeah
i was like oh this [ __ ] is this is
undeniable like the shine video was so
crazy
like but um talk about that like
like did did you ever flirt with the
idea of
of moving on from music at all um
never like fully moving on
it was just like that's how i got into
business though right in
entrepreneurship like because
i would never like move on for music
because i've been doing music since i
was eight years old
right so before i was making money off
of music i love making music so that's
something like i'ma always do
i just had to take away the pressure of
making money from the [ __ ]
i'm not stupid you know what i mean i'm
a hustler so
the moment i had to really realize like
okay the reason why this [ __ ] stresses
me the [ __ ] out
is because we have millions of views
thousands of
thousands and thousands of fans right
but we're not rich
like we're not like comfortable we're
not living like we should be i don't
[ __ ] my money off i'm not addicted to no
crazy like
smoke weed you know i'm not like a idiot
so why the [ __ ]
why ain't it going crazy other than
people [ __ ] us and deals i was gonna
say was it do you think that's what it
was you guys had shitty deals
100 um i mean
yeah both i mean our first deal we got
our first deal was like almost 800 000
and me and our team split 15 racks we
took
15 racks back to the ie 7 500 back to
the ie
wait wait wait wait wait so it was 800
000 deal
800 000 and you guys signed to a
production company we didn't know the
game didn't know nobody was a production
company
they they got to touch the money first
obviously so whatever the initial
real events was whatever that two three
hundred thousand following
whatever the [ __ ] wasn't negotiated
thank you cleaned up
and we got 15 racks wow to split
and it took 7 500 today and for me [ __ ]
i thought
[ __ ] we was good who was that it's my
cousin
[Music]
[ __ ] down and piss in the bed with this
[ __ ] and like 7500 i took that to the
head [ __ ] we thought it was right
shot mom's a couple bags you know they
got when they bought all type of [ __ ]
[ __ ] and then you were doing shows
exactly but you guys were doing shows we
were doing shows yeah you guys are doing
little shows different
[ __ ] game bro these kids now like
well back then i feel like y'all were
doing like a lot of 18 and up parties
like no
not even that don't even matter bro the
shows we were doing
[ __ ] was doing thousands like shows
with thousands
of people like and that and low we were
doing an
800 capacity [ __ ] show with kids and
some wild [ __ ] like that
we was doing [ __ ] big shows every
other like at least twice a week and
whatnot make a long story short
one the internet wasn't like it is now
like i was like myspace
you know and so how was it the social
thing was not even a thing for real so
like the aspect of
fully becoming like these mega stars
like like a trippy red
can now was but [ __ ] being a mega star
the money
these [ __ ] do [ __ ] 10 shows these
[ __ ] is
millionaires now like back then it
wasn't that and it was just a different
game we didn't know no better
the the um appreciation for black
music and rap wasn't where was that we
were still competing with
even yo back i was gonna say back then
when y'all were like bubbling
up first it was like pit bull and lady
gaga yeah
all that [ __ ] that was it was it was
one of the dark ages of music
black eyed peas we were black these
whack ass they was getting compared to
black eyed people they were making
[ __ ]
you know they asked somebody they had
some big records like i got a feeling
but i i
bro it's because i lived in vegas at
that time right and that's when
everything in vegas changed where every
time you go to the club you wouldn't
hear rap it was all about the fist pump
128 bpms
and then neo started making whack ass
[ __ ]
all these r b [ __ ] started
making chris brown started making whack
ass [ __ ] yeah
start going to a weird place it was like
everybody was making
[ __ ] whack dance music and some of
that [ __ ] was begging forever it was a
bop
they had bobs in it but they definitely
would get into a place even us as
creative we were getting to a place
where we were trying to force them
because they were that was what was
right pop that was what was being told
in first
lmfs oh my god i wanted them oh my god
and uh you know all them type of people
that's who we were getting compared